welcome everybody to a kaggle coding
adventure with lux ai lux ai is a
currently running kaggle competition
where players face off in a 1v1
challenge to collect resources and end
the game with the largest cities there
are lots of details to the game and
knowing them will certainly help you to
win the competition but i do find with
competitions like this that i've done in
the past it's usually best to just try
to make something basic and then build
from there rather than attempting to be
the best right out of the gate there are
tiers of workers tiers of resources
those resources have varying
requirements to obtain there's a
day-night cycle where in the night you
need enough resources to produce light
or those city tiles die and so on coding
all this can represent a decent
challenge alone much less competing
against other people and strategies so
i'll be starting off simple then slowly
building out from there i don't expect
anything that i come up with at least
initially or even within a few hours to
be competitive in any way but i do enjoy
this style of competition
[Music]
to begin we need to acquire lux locally
this is going to vary based on your
operating system so check the github
page and follow the instructions if you
want to follow along essentially it is
just merely installing node.js then
installing the challenge
from there we can check out the kits
directory and then in here we can see
there's some examples in various
programming languages for coding your ai
i'm interested in python so i'll click
that and then in here we have this
simple directory
if we check out the simple directory
this is a complete submission ready
example that you could zip up and upload
to kaggle for competition
that said the bot here is way too
primitive to actually compete with you
just embarrass yourself so we'll start
by running things locally and then
tinkering from there so for me i've
copied the simple directory inside here
we have of main interest to us we've got
the lux package in python but then
mainly agent.pi and main.pi so i'll pull
those over here we have main.pi
essentially just runs your agent you
don't really need to mess with this at
all and you really shouldn't other than
maybe if you change agent here or this
pi file to something else and so on so
then we check out agent.pie this is what
contains your actual logic and strategy
and all that so we'll be digging more
into this very soon but first let's go
ahead and run this and see what things
look like so now to actually run this
we're going to go back one directory
since we're in the simple ai directory
and in theory this is our actual agent
so i'll go back one directory and just
run a game of simple versus simple so
i'll open up a terminal here drag that
over make that slightly bigger and then
run the following command and in this
case it's npx run lux ai and then this
is ai number one that's going to compete
versus ai number two in this case it
just happens to be the exact same ai and
then this is the game size so we're
going to do a 24 by 24 game map and
we'll go ahead and run that and we
should see that we wind up with a
replays directory so if we double click
on that we see there's some sort of json
file that is the replay
and if we want to look at this we can
either come over to the lux viewer and
view this like offline so if we want to
just use it locally we could do that so
we can essentially just host the viewer
locally or we can use the following uh
it's at
2021viz.lux-ai.org and we can upload the
replay so we can run that real quick
and in general so over here we have like
the stats and stuff like that and then
down here you can press play and you can
like speed it up by pressing play but
it's really annoying to like do that
every single time and as time goes on
you'll probably run many iterations and
this is like super slow even this is
slower than i would want it to be so
i've personally found that when i look
at replays i just click this and just
kind of drag it around and if i see
anything that looks interesting i'll
kind of go back and watch it maybe a
little slower but in general i just kind
of drag this around
and then you can look over here you can
see city fuel you can even click on like
specific units so you can click on like
your worker you can click on your city
tiles you can click on these resource
tiles and so on
[Music]
the objective of this competition is to
simply end the game with more city tiles
than the opponent that's all there is to
it of the slightly over 400 teams
currently participating in the
competition the bottom 125 or so at the
time of my recording are all just
keeping a mere single city tile like the
simple bot does here
so the tiny change of merely building
one more city tile would put us above
about 25 percent of the competition so
let's go ahead and do that also while
we're doing that one issue that creeps
up a lot especially with coding a
strategy bot like this is that code can
explode and get really messy really fast
because you're gonna try a strategy try
another strategy you're gonna have a
bunch of logic that corresponds maybe
just to one strategy and and so on and
things just get really messy now i'm no
pillar of organization but i'm going to
do some housekeeping with the bot even
just the simple bot right here as i run
through the existing code and we make
some changes to build one more city to
start the first 32 lines are probably
good enough to keep as they are
after this though we come across the
first block of code that could easily be
a function which is the creation of this
list that contains the resource tile
objects
we're not going to save total line count
in the file here by turning this into a
function but instead we're looking to
abstract away our code logic from the
strategy logic as much as possible so as
to make the strategy logic as clear as
possible
so for this we'll define resource tiles
as get resource tiles and pass the game
state width and height this function
doesn't exist yet so i'll copy the code
block that defined these in the first
place go and make a new function called
get resource tiles and then paste in
this code at the end i'll return the
resource tiles and there's our first bit
of cleaned up logic
the next chunk of code that i'll address
here is the code that simply finds a
resource i'll use a similar method here
to just say the closest resource tile is
equal to the return of a function called
get close resource and pass the unit
resource tiles and player object then i
cut the code go to the top to find a new
function called get close resource paste
in the code and add the parameters
continuing along in the code same thing
here where there's a block of code that
simply finds the closest city tile to
return to with our resources
i'll establish the variable to be equal
to the return of a function called get
close city paste in the code and realize
that i never actually returned the
closest resource tile in the above and
previous function so add that in and
then of course also a return closest
city tile for that get close city
function
and now we've considerably simplified
our actual agent function again we
didn't remove code in the total file we
actually added more lines here but the
idea is to keep the agent function our
logic or strategy as simple and easy to
understand as possible for ourselves
especially as we begin to add much much
more logic
the next thing to do is run the code
make sure there are no errors and check
the replay to make sure everything is
acting as expected looks good to me
now to beat those hundred or so
competitors we really just need to build
one more city tile checking the
documentation to do this requires a unit
with 100 units of resources and then we
just call unit.build city we really just
want to do this once so just build one
more city tile for now and to do this we
need to know how many do we actually
have scrolling up in the documentation
we can see that we can find this out
possibly through player.cities but it's
kind of unclear to me what this is
to help us here i'll be bringing in
logging due to how the game itself is
using terminal outputs to actually play
the game we can't really use prints here
plus the game moves so fast that an
actual log file i think would be more
useful anyway
i'll specify my log file and start
things off by just simply logging this
player.cities value then i'll run the
code check the log file and it appears
what we have here is indeed some sort of
id for the key and then the city object
as the value one thing to note
immediately here is that we have both
cities and city tiles
adjacent city tiles are part of the same
city so cities are comprised of city
tiles
coming back to my code i'll specify then
that the cities are now
player.cities.values
and the city tiles which we want two of
for now will be an empty list to start
and then i'll iterate through all cities
and then all city tiles in those cities
city tiles
and add those to my city tiles list
finally i'll log the cities and city
tiles just to make sure my logic and
things are working how i expect running
this i'm initially confused because log
files are appended and i'm not seeing
the new information because i'm scrolled
up to the top thinking it'll help i add
some text to differentiate these and
upon seeing it doesn't help i realize my
mistake and i find that um i find what i
was expecting by simply scrolling down
clearing the log file and running again
much better that's what i wanted and
everything is indeed looking as i
expected one city tile and one city
and now it's time to crush my opponents
before iterating over units i'll set a
new variable called build city to false
and then i'll check to see if the list
of city tiles is less than two
if it is then i want to build another
city tile
so then we begin iterating through the
workers we know we need a hundred units
of resources to build a city and each
worker unit holds 100 resources so if
the unit's cargo space left is more than
zero we need to just keep gathering
else if build city is true then we'll
log that we do wish to build a city but
where
deciding where to build is all by itself
another part of the strategy so for now
let's just try to build adjacent so that
it stays a part of one single city i'll
set a global variable called build
location at the top of the script come
down to the agent function and add it as
a global and then begin to build the
logic what we really want to do here is
find an empty tile next to our current
city tile so first i grab that close
city tile then build a list of
directional changes we're working in xy
coordinates so adding 1 to the x
position of the city tile checks the
tile to the east of that tile and one to
the y would check the tile to the south
and so on for the negatives there may be
times where these spots are all filled
this is something we'll handle for
another time so we'll iterate through
those directions and check for emptiness
allowing for errors and sometimes your
city tile might actually be on the edge
of the map so we'll check for a tile
that doesn't even exist but we'd also
like to see any other errors that we
didn't even think about too
for each tile we'll see if it has any
resources any road or any existing city
tile already on it
if it doesn't great that's our build
location and let's break out of the loop
then we'll check if the unit is already
at the build location if it is build the
city note that you need to define the
action then append it to the list of
actions this full list of actions is
what the game reads and acts on
after building we'll set build city to
false and build location back to none
and continue if we don't need to find
the build location and we're not yet at
the build location but we have a build
location then we wish to navigate to
that location
so we'll append that action with a
unit.move to the direction of the build
location unit moves are actually in
north south east west or center and
basically denoted as n s e w and c not
in coordinates so keep that in mind so
when you do a unit dot move it's
actually an n s e w or c
eventually we'll need to probably create
our own pathing function rather than
using this one since it doesn't handle
for things like avoiding unit collisions
and other problems so we'll need to get
more into these movements later probably
now i want to run everything and make
sure it works and there's some error
with logging
this error makes no sense to me it still
makes no sense to me it seems to be
logging related despite using logging
earlier just fine it appears to be
caused somehow by it but i just i have
no idea why
but commenting out the logs and running
appears to work as expected
so rather than using logging i'll just
try out a typical file i'll define its
name and then go ahead and open it with
a write intention purely to clear the
file every time
next everywhere i was logging and still
want to log some info i'll instead add
an open file to append option and write
what i want i could also encase the
whole agent function in this open so i
don't need to keep calling the with open
but i don't intend to be doing a ton of
logging i'll probably regret this later
running things again i get an error i
forget the quotes in step i do a find
and replace run again and of course my
replace causes a new error we're using
double quotes inside of double quotes
run again and i see i'm not getting a
second city tile checking the logs i see
we're indeed hitting that error
exception and logging it
after some poking around i realized that
after all of this in the condition where
we have the build location that we wish
to navigate to
after we hit that else we're going to
actually continue this block and hit
that final if statement which then
instead instructs the exact same unit to
go find the closest city tile to remedy
this i'll add a continue after the units
move to the build location trying again
things run no errors but i don't see a
second city tile with either agent in
the replay looking at the log file i see
we wanted to build a second city we
really did but then we don't what's up
running it again and checking the replay
we can see things actually worked this
time for both agents so what actually
happened here well like i said the
default navigation is kind of silly
anytime an agent runs over a city tile
all of the resources are deposited there
so what was happening was our agent
tried to move to a tile that was across
a city tile deposited everything
then had cargo space so it went back to
collect and repeated this over and over
now actually if we want to build
adjacent to a city tile i believe we can
do that with zero resources on the
worker i think the worker actually
subtracts or the resources get
subtracted from the adjacent city tile
but that's not the logic i was intending
here so we really
we want something to fix this
and at this point i'm starting to
realize i might not be very good at this
competition
and how much time will be required to
actually make a decent bot
[Music]
so the first thing i've done is copied
the simple directory and called it
intermediate and in here this is the
agent that i'm going to continue working
on to begin expanding the city we can
just build another city tile but then
our upkeep is higher so we want more
workers too
i think i want to have one worker per
city tile but we cannot build another
worker first since in order to build
workers you need to have less workers
than city tiles
to start building city tiles i think we
also want to start tracking workers the
resources those workers are using and
the city tiles that those workers
deposit to initially if we're just
building one big city we don't need to
associate workers to that city tile but
if we want to start expanding we need to
at least probably associate workers to
the overall city that they're depositing
to but for now i'll just map to this
specific city tile along with mapping
workers to resources using a couple of
global dictionaries next when looking
for a resource we'll skip a resource if
it's already a resource for a different
worker later we might elect to allow for
two or three or any number of workers to
share a resource tile but this is
something worthy of trial and error
later for now i'll just assign one one
per in the agent function i'll add the
two global dictionaries i'll add a list
that contains all workers that i can
reference and iterate through and then i
am checking to see if those workers
exist in the unit to city dictionary if
not i'll just assign them to a closed
city and then i do the exact same thing
for workers and resources then i already
know that i'm going to want more than
two city tiles so i'm going to change
the build city boolean criteria to
instead be a measure of the ratio of
workers to city tiles again the specific
number that i'm going to go with here is
something that could easily be tuned
fuel burn rates per city tile varies
based on the city's size so it's
possible that one worker unit could
theoretically serve two or more city
tiles or maybe 20 workers could serve 30
city tiles and so on or maybe it's
better to have a worker per city tile
next when iterating over units and
filling cargo we'll grab the resource
tile to head for from the unit resource
dictionary now instead it's probably
wise to confirm this cell has a resource
still and if not get a new one and
assign that unit to the new one if we do
want to build i still am okay with the
logic for the build location so i'm
ready to go ahead and extract this out
into its own function so now the build
location will be the return of a new
function called find empty tile near i'm
also going to go ahead and add in
checking for the diagonal tiles for
response 2. this is mostly a copy and
paste and could definitely be made quite
a bit better with i don't know something
like a for loop over the two types of
directions or something like that but
this will do for now i'm also going to
change this alif to an if because we
might as well issue a unit's navigation
even if we need to define the build
location first and then i'll change the
final if to an l if the continues i
think should stop us from landing here
anyways but i'm just throwing it in just
in case then rather than returning to
the closest city we'll return to this
unit's specified city tile if the unit
doesn't have one we'll get a new one
running things i see that we just need
to move our resource tiles definition a
bit up since we're referencing it
earlier in some of the new logic another
run another issue a typo fix that run
again we do get another city so that is
indeed what we expected checking the
logs however i see that we're constantly
finding a worker without a city or a
resource and that's not expected i also
note here that each unit object here is
a new or different object in memory so
that's kind of a problem because we're
using the object itself as the key
checking the docs though i see that
units also have unique ids maybe we can
use that value instead so i'm going to
go ahead and change all the references
of the worker to instead be worker dot
id essentially and running again things
look much better
the next order of business for me is to
address the running over of city tiles
and depositing all of our cargo when we
do it if we want to avoid doing this we
need to navigate around the city there
may be times where we also want to
navigate around an enemy city or
something like this and this logic could
be used for that under the build city if
statement we want to address the final
else where we actually navigate to that
build location the logic here is first
to determine what is the x and y
coordinate difference between our
current position and the one that we
want to be at then take note that
movement commands for units are not
actually coordinates but instead are n s
e w or c for north south east west or
center so i'll make note of what
coordinates would translate to what
directions then whichever absolute value
is greater in the coordinate differences
we'll just assume that's the direction
that we want to start off going so then
i'll check the tile one step in that
direction to see if it is empty if it is
great we'll go that way if not we'll go
in the other direction that we need to
go instead this logic could probably be
improved pretty significantly and a
small wall of city tiles would be enough
i think to actually thwart this
completely but running this i forgot to
import numpy so i'll do that run again
and i see that we still tied but that's
because both teams built a second city
there wasn't really a city tile in the
way trying again i see an instance where
the intermediate bot won so let's check
that replay i see indeed that my unit
went around the other city tile finally
just to make things a bit more clear in
the logs i'll add a log when the city is
actually built running one more time and
checking the logs things are looking
pretty good here
now that i've got the logic for workers
to build more city tiles i need the
logic to build more workers to do this
i'll continue building workers until i
have as many workers as city tiles i'll
iterate over all city tiles and if that
city tile can build a worker i'll go
ahead and do that while i'm here since
we need to do research to eventually get
coal and uranium i'll also do research
if i cannot build another worker running
this i can see that i've hit a div by
zero error which can really only mean
that i had zero city tiles checking the
replay i can see that i indeed expanded
too quickly and the city did not survive
the night there are kind of two issues
here one obviously ideally this just
wouldn't happen and two we could have
easily just rebuilt new city tiles
during this game if we wanted to and we
wouldn't have necessarily ended with
zero city tiles and we would have beat
the other bot so first we'll determine
if we really should build more city
tiles to do this i'll figure out which
city we're going to build on to and then
get the fuel for that city then we can
divide the total city fuel by the size
of that city giving us a about average
number of fuel per city tile and really
we're just looking for a way to have
enough fuel per city tile to make it
through the night so now i can pick some
number like 300 units of fuel per city
and if we have more than that we can
allow ourselves to build another city
tile i'll log some of the information
and then add an if statement to handle
for if we have the fuel to build or not
if we don't have the fuel i'll just
sloppily copy and paste the code to go
find a city to dump the resources into
running things i see i've got an error
about the resource assignment variable
it looks like somehow in a copy and
paste frenzy i left in old names or
something fixing that and things are
getting closer to what i want though now
units are running into each other a lot
and getting stuck
running again i get another div by zero
issue when all of my city tiles have
died so what i'll do here is encase the
build city boolean and try and accept
and set it to true in the exception case
truly expert coding and running this
things are looking better but still
having problems with collisions
[Music]
to handle for these collisions my first
idea is to create another global
dictionary that tracks unit positions
over steps
if that unit has stayed at the same
coordinates for some number of steps
it's stuck and we want to move it for
now i propose that movement is
random for each step i'll iterate
through the workers and if they're
already in this like worker positions
dictionary i'll append the new position
if not then i'll create a new key where
the value is a deck with a maximum
length of three essentially we'll just
store the last three positions of each
worker i'm going to go ahead and log
this dictionary and run things to see if
things are looking as i expect they sure
do and i can already see workers that
are definitely stuck to hopefully remedy
this we'll check the last positions so
long as we have two or more in this deck
then we're going to check how many
unique values using a set of the list of
the deck
if there's only one unique coordinate
pair this unit must be stuck so i'll log
that and then move a random choice
between north south east or west running
this i get a list index out of range
error checking the replay i see this
makes sense since the entire city died
to solve for this some more expert
coding with a try and accept if we hit
an exception i'll just continue
next i get a build location that is none
as the city grows there will be many
times where there's no directly
surrounding tiles that we could build on
i think here we could actually like loop
and use some sort of range to keep
checking more and more distant tiles and
a further away radius instead of just
one out
but for now
how about another try and accept i'll
sort the exceptions to the logs so we
can handle those later
running this a few times i can see that
things are looking up for me and my
empire is forming
at this point i'd say we're pretty close
to something good enough as a first
submission and a decent starting point
to leave everyone on without raising the
bar
probably at all this will probably be a
pretty average bot the last thing i'll
share is a way to test hyper parameter
changes to your agent we have lots of
values like city fuel how many units
could share a resource and even more
nebulous things like maybe a new
navigation or avoidance logic you
probably have many ideas of how to
improve things already from what you've
seen here or maybe a curiosity about
what might change if you tweak certain
things so one option is to just simply
log how many city tiles you have ended
the game with so i'll just create a name
and then at the very end if the
observation step is 359 the very last
step of the game
write out how many city tiles we have
we can use this to compare two agents
and count wins and games or even just
the average number of city tiles in
general that this agent is capable of
creating so here for example i'm
comparing the agent code that we've
built up to this point and then agent r
d is with one change which is to find an
empty tire radius that can be greater
than one
that one change made a pretty
considerable impact in the average city
tiles created
you should also be probably paying
attention to
any scenarios where you ended with zero
city tiles these are often just
throwaway games that you could have made
a tiny change to to save it
there are many improvements that we
could make here we could definitely
clean up this code a ton like we did in
the beginning just to make it easier to
read and i'm sure there are even bugs in
my logic we could also eke out more
performance by doing things like paying
attention to how close is the night so
cycles are in 40 steps
30 of those are days and then 10 are
nights well we could be far more
expansive maybe in the first 15 days and
then settle down and adhere more
strictly to fuel requirements as we
approach nighttime stuff like that
there's so many things that we can do
but i still think this is a pretty good
stopping point uh and a place for people
to build on if they want when you're
ready to submit you just compress to a
tar.gz and then you can submit your bot
within about five minutes you should
start seeing matches against other
people
after about a day my score with this
agent was 656 which leaves a lot of room
for improvement i also see there are
over 500 teams now so there's even more
competition to play with
so definitely check it out if you are
interested i'll also put a link to my
ending code up to this point in the
description so if you want to take it
and start cleaning it up and adding your
own logic go ahead
this video is sponsored by udacity which
is currently offering 75 off of all of
their nano degrees if you use code
centex 21. they've just recently redone
the self-driving car nanodegree which
i've spent some time checking out and
would definitely recommend if you're
interested but the discount code works
on any of the nanodegrees so feel free
to pick something else that piques your
interest i'll put links in the
description that you can use for the 75
off and thank you to udacity for
supporting the content
you